[Music]
dad
let me also get my notes up here so that
i don't leave anything out
there we go
maybe maybe
can't read that there we go
well we do want to welcome you here this
evening and with you and you're with us
online we want to welcome you uh into
the room with us
uh we want to be one in this uh service
tonight
we're glad you're here we're glad you're
with us online
we have a couple of announcements we
need to make here first of all super
bowl sunday which is next sunday of
course
the services if you haven't been told
yet are going to be at 4 p.m rather than
5 p.m
so that we can be home by 5 30 for the
start of what the pastor has said right
here
is a significant annual cultural
so
that comes from the top so it must be so
right regardless if you're not a fan of
either one of the other teams this is a
significant cultural event okay so
uh also the welcome to the table class
uh will be february 28th or 20th i'm
sorry right after the service it's a
good class if you haven't been we've
been through it we really enjoyed it
learned a lot about the church
and about possibilities for ministry and
so on and so forth so
it's perfect for those wanting to become
official church members of the table or
for those just wanting to simply learn
more about who we are
be hosted by brett the same one who said
that it's a significant cultural event
this also will be a significant cultural
event i guarantee it
so we would like you if you are
interested to fill out one of these
little cards it's right out there on
that table after the service today
and uh put put your name and your
contact info on it and note welcome
class so that we will know why you put
it if you're simply visiting and you're
not interested in that please fill out
one of these cards as well and put it in
that little box as you leave today
okay we're going to prepare now for
worship
and uh if you just join me in prayer
appreciate it father
thank you for the opportunity to gather
this evening together
we thank you father that as we come
before you
in whatever state of mind we might be in
in whatever condition
of readiness or holiness we might
perceive ourselves to be
we thank you that you remind us that you
are the very way forward
that you are the truth of our readiness
that you have indeed
qualified us in christ jesus
and so we just offer this time up to you
but a time also
which which we invite you to just
refresh us with the understanding that
you are indeed the way the truth and the
life
thank you father for the opportunity to
be here together tonight in jesus
awesome name amen
amen
all right thanks mike if you guys would
stand with us as we sing we are going to
um go into this first song that says
exactly that scripture that he was just
saying he is our way and even if there
are parts of christianity or the bible
or faith or your life that do not make
sense that you are not totally bought
into right now that you are not sure if
you agree with or not one thing that i
have found extremely comforting about
the way of jesus is that none of that
has ever been
something that separates me from his
love
so like mike was saying bring all your
stuff
bring your whole self
because his love is here and it is
present and it is ready for us to engage
with and uh josh is going to lead us
through this first song so you guys just
follow him and join in as you feel
comfortable
[Music]
i believe that you are my fortress
you are my portion
you are my hiding place
i believe you are
the way
the truth
the life
i believe
[Music]
you are the one i love
the truth
i believe
[Music]
the
the way
[Music]
on you
did you meet me here today
mercies that i knew
it's all my fears and doubts
they can all come true
they can't stay long
when i'm here with you
it's a new
horizon and i've set on you
you need me here today
mercies that are new
until my fears in doubt
they can all come true
because they can't stay long
when i believe you are
the
way the truth
is
[Music]
the life
i believe you are
[Music]
yes god thank you
you broke my chains of sin
and shame and you covered me with grace
[Music]
you cover me with grace
it is for freedom
that i am
free
you broke my chain
of sin and shame and you covered me with
grace
[Music]
i am
it is
[Music]
and yes lord we
are grateful for
yes lord we
are grateful
for your grace and for
[Music]
yes lord we
are grateful for your grace and for your
love
[Music]
it is for
that i am
[Music]
me
we're going to move into the prayers of
the people which is a christian
tradition back throughout christian
history that we enjoy bringing into our
current service
and tonight instead of us kind of taking
turns reading if you guys would just
read the whole thing aloud with me
as we go through it and then we'll break
if this is your first time here that's a
time for all of us to share a name or a
situation that you're carrying that
might be weighing on your heart tonight
or just one that you're keeping in your
prayers just share that name out loud
and we will lift them up together and
then i'll um
close us out and you guys can pray that
last part of the prayer with me again
jesus for the city of saxi texas and for
every city and community and all of
those who live in them
we pray to you
for the good earth that you have given
us and the wisdom and the will to
conserve it
we pray to you
for those who travel on land sea or air
for the old and the sick for the widow
and the orphan for the injured and the
suffering we pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed the
unemployed and destitute for prisoners
and captives and for all who remember
and care for them
we pray to you
lord we know that you love us and that
you hear us
and so we lift these names and
situations up to you
chelsea
[Music]
michael johnson
is
[Music]
for the names and moments that we've
spoken aloud and for those that we've
kept in our hearts
we pray to you that they may have life
and light
healing and hope
peace and a deep sense of your presence
amen
[Music]
um we're gonna try a new song tonight
um
and when i recently heard it what i
loved about it the most was the bridge
kind of has this gospel
feel to it for any of you who like some
good gospel music
as a kid sometimes we would wake up on
sunday mornings and my dad would be
blaring gospel music in the kitchen
while he made us cinnamon toast
which was a favorite
of ours
but as many of you know this is black
history month and
although that is
um
an experience a lived experience that i
don't have and can't completely
understand
i love taking the space and the time to
acknowledge another community and what
they've experienced what history has
brought their way what they have lived
through
and acknowledge both the pain and the
victory
and take the time and space to connect
with that
in what ways we can
and
this song is actually based on
a scripture it's in um second
corinthians
the verse the specific verses 3 17
um
and it's talking about how in the past
um christians when they would talk about
moses or even when moses had his lived
experience with god they would cover
their faces with a veil
you know
because he had experienced the glory of
the lord and it was like too bright and
powerful for everyone to see and
um and that's kind of what they're
talking about right here and it says
even to this day when moses is read a
veil covers their hearts
but when everyone turns to the lord
the veil is taken away
now the lord is spirit and where the
spirit of the lord is there is freedom
and we who with unveiled faces all
reflect the lord's glory
we are being transformed into his
likeness with ever increasing glory
which comes from the lord who is spirit
and i was just thinking about that word
freedom
where his spirit is there is freedom and
what that word must mean to people who
have lived a different experience than
me to the black community who
literally went through chains
and then experienced you know step by
step hopefully more and more what true
freedom is
and um
i just wanted us to take this time
during this song to reflect a little bit
on what that word might mean for you
and
where are the areas where you've
experienced his freedom
where are the areas where you still need
to experience more of his freedom maybe
it's with mental
health maybe it's with physical
addictions maybe it's relationships that
we're still carrying pain and hurt from
maybe it's our own shortcomings that we
cannot forgive ourselves for and we are
continuing to hold up a measure that god
is not holding up for us
um but whatever it is for us tonight i
just want to invite us all into a place
where we're in we're asking god to bring
us freedom
because he is spirit and we are spirit
and where that spirit is there is
freedom
so we have access to that and i don't
mean that in a weird kooky way i mean in
a tangible
real present way
let's connect with the freedom of god
and expect that it is still changing
lives it is still removing chains it's
still breaking through strongholds and
setting us free
to be who christ created us to be
so um i hope you guys will
be encouraged as we sing this to grab
hold of that freedom and to remember the
stories of other people's lives who have
taken hold of freedom in their own ways
amen
[Music]
amen sing that with us all together
amen amen
one more time amen
amen
[Music]
that i can explain peace that steals my
soul
light in the darkest place life
even in the pain it feels like common
hall where the spirit
where the spirit of the lord is there is
freedom
i am free
[Music]
there is freedom
i am
[Music]
praise god who saved
there is freedom i am free amen
when the spirit of the lord is there is
freedom
i am
[Music]
i am free amen can you put your hands
together
free
at last
[Music]
thank god almighty i am free and lasting
and again free
at last
[Music]
they've
where the spirit
of the lord is there is freedom
i am free amen
where the spirit of the lord
[Music]
there is
there is freedom
i am free amen
scott thank you that you're always
pulling us forward
calling us into more freedom
seeing us as the people that you created
whole
with purpose
and beauty
with meaning
you see us as worthy
you love us
would those be the truths that we
carried through our lives would be the
would they be the truths that we pass on
to the other people we're in
relationship with
would be the story that we tell our
children
you are free
you are loved you are whole and worthy
thank you god for your spirit
would it continue to show us where we're
walking with chains and would it set
them free god
thank you for this community
thank you for the way that we can
shoulder each other's burdens and call
out the best in one another would we be
that would we be that reflection of
jesus in each other
it's in your name i ask all these things
amen
all right thank you guys y'all can go
ahead and take a seat and as you do can
you turn to the people around you and
welcome them make them feel at home and
then brett will get us started with our
message
well good evening
grace and peace
welcome to the table it is uh super good
to be with all of you
y'all doing well
feeling good yeah that was a beautiful
beautiful worship set thank you
uh mindy and maggie and joe and josh
we are um we're very blessed as a church
to have folks like them leading us each
week so
um all right so we are um well like uh
like mindy mentioned it is black history
month
and so
um i want to first give just a uh a
shout out to all of our african american
brothers and sisters whether here or
online we love you lots
and and as a as a church community that
is um not exclusively but um
is uh kind of predominantly you know
white i want to encourage us to take
take space this month to um
you know to learn like there's obviously
things you cover like in elementary
school or junior high or high school or
whatever and um you know it's easy to
have no continuing education
and such things and uh and i don't just
mean like history around slavery or
anything but um even after that you know
jim crow era and into civil rights era
and even today um
the experiences of of black folks and
and things they're going through and
it's just it's good to i mean we are
vision here
at the um table is to be um basically a
community who's shifting a generation
from reactionary to visionary through
the person and work of jesus
and i think in order to um get out of a
reactionary mode it's often helpful to
um know like um to understand you know
like when you can at least understand um
someone better like that helps you shift
out of kind of reactionary afraid
um and it can shift you into a more
visionary christ-like way of being so um
i encourage this to take some space
whether it's like reading a book or
listening to a podcast or watching a
documentary on netflix or i don't know
however whatever your like medium of
choice is for such things
i encourage you to do that so um we are
continuing in our series titled um first
peter part two
and um
we're basically just walking our way
through the book of first peter so um
we're going to we've covered chapter one
we're now into chapter two um actually
this message will wrap up chapter two
next week we'll go into chapter three um
we'll do just kind of finishing um
february we'll finish chapter three and
then we'll hit the pause button it will
be the season of lent um in the the
church which is kind of the season of
the cross as we go into easter and all
that so um so we'll kind of hit the
pause button and then we'll come back
eventually we will make our way through
this whole book
but it's a process right no rush no rush
so um so we're at towards the end of
chapter two and so the title of my
message tonight if you're a note taker
you can jot this down is um accept
reject subvert transform
accept reject subvert transform lots of
words
what does that even mean well
that's what we're gonna get into
so um
i um
i mentioned last week one of the uh kind
of it's a good thing it's a challenging
thing but a good thing about um
preaching like or kind of walking
through a book like a whole book of the
bible as opposed to doing something more
topical um
you know for example i think at some
point in this year we'll probably do a
series like on prayer and that's kind of
a topic you know then i get to kind of
pick and choose the verses
which also means i get to pick and
choose um which verses not to cover
right and that's the thing with going
through a book of the bible is you don't
really get to do that the next sermon is
on
whatever the next verses are and um and
so
that that means of course you know
pastor's always very good about like
kind of picking and choosing and
avoiding at times and certain texts and
things um and so the text tonight
maybe a little bit of last week more
tonight and next week are um definitely
passages that
preachers tend to skip you know even if
you come from a more kind of liturgical
tradition um
whether like methodism or roman
catholicism whatever like even the
liturgies will tend to kind of
just kind of jumping over these texts
like you know just not not dealing with
them and uh so i don't you know as a
church community i think it's good for
us not to um run from
things run from the bible or run from
passages um even ones that kind of
strike us as like
kind of cringy and difficult um but
rather just you know don't be afraid but
like press into him so that's what we're
that's what we're gonna do does that
sound good
so um you nod your heads
cautiously that was very kind like
maybe i'll just go ahead and do this
because that's what you want me to do
that's that's what your head said um
so and i should also mention it's um
i'll call it just divine providence that
um
we happen to be in this text which was
used by
white christians to defend the
institution of slavery in the united
states for a long time and we just
happened i didn't actually plan it this
way but here we are first sunday of
black history month and this is the text
um so i'll just take it as divine
providence and we're supposed to deal
with this so
um
let me go ahead and read it uh starting
in chapter 2 of first peter
verse 18.
he says slaves
in reverent fear of god submit
yourselves to your masters
and not only to those who are good and
considerate but also to those who are
harsh for it is commendable if someone
bears up under the pain of unjust
suffering because they are conscious of
god but how is it to your credit if you
receive a beating for doing wrong and
endure it but if you suffer for doing
good
and you endure it this is commendable
before god
to this you were called because christ
suffered for you leaving you an example
that you should follow in his
steps
um i probably don't have to explain how
that could be
incredibly problematic um
yeah it's fairly obvious so now what i
want to name and kind of as we get into
this is um there's an old saying in uh
anyone who goes like seminary or bible
college or something to learn about how
to study the bible there's this old
saying and its context is king
context is king
and uh what that plucky little saying
means cutesy little saying is uh
basically that to understand um a given
you know passage or verse you know
understanding the historical context
around it is incredibly essential um
because um it can change the way you
interpret it right um
and so kind of what i want to do where i
want to start tonight
is um by looking at two we'll call them
um sort of contextual
um cultural
insights from peter's day and time when
he's writing
that i think give us really essential
information kind of background um to
know what peter's doing and what he's
not doing
in a way that's really what these clues
are about is really naming what is he
not doing
um that
he was often interpreted that he was so
um all right if you're a notetaker you
can jot this down contextual insight
number one
peter is not defending slavery as a
cultural institution
he is simply accepting it as a cultural
given
um in other words
you know if you look at the broader
context so like last week we were
looking at the whole passage where he
talks about you know submit to the
ruling authorities right he's talking to
christians and and we kind of delved
into the ruling authorities for these uh
these churches that he's writing to
they're in rome
so he's really talking there about the
roman empire and so while on the surface
it can it could sound like he's kind of
saying you know well submit to the
ruling authorities because they are
moral and right and good and you know
everyone's established by god so you got
to obey and that's we looked at last
week and that's not what he's getting at
um he's talking really it was more
practical it was about christian witness
they're in the roman empire
yes rome as an empire was morally
reprehensible and terrible
but he was saying okay
what do we as you know christians how do
we act in this setting
um
we we submit to the ruling authorities
as best we can and you know and it kind
of goes on from there so
um in a similar way well and actually
we'll see
next week um you've got something going
on very similarly where he writes to um
christian
wives submitting to husbands it's kind
of a similar kind of dynamic so um
thinking in terms of master slave
in the same way he wasn't saying rome is
moral and awesome and right therefore
submit because it's right in everything
it says and does i think in a similar
way he's not saying
slave submit to your masters because the
cultural institution of slavery is
established by god himself therefore to
you know push back on that is to oppose
the very will of god like that's where i
think we can start to read that into the
text but it's not actually there
right um
he's just basically when i say accepting
as a cultural given you know in our day
and age it's sort of obvious that like
wait what
you don't just accept slavery like you
don't just be like well yeah is what it
is like what no you fight it and oppose
it and
like it's terrible you know um this is
where we have to kind of bridge the gap
2 000 years ago
the idea of i mean
uh well slavery it was nearly as old as
like human history it's it was just a
given in the culture at the time it was
just on no one's radar not peter's not
anyone in rome
not really anyone in the broader world
as far as um we know at least from my
research it's just the idea of like
let's in this horrible institution was
just
not like a thing
right so we can kind of look back and be
kind of frustrated with peter like come
on man this is embarrassing
but i think if we were kind of in his
own context um
i think we would understand that it was
it just was
um also again keep in mind these are
like christians were like a small little
minority in the broader roman empire so
this isn't you know three or four
hundred years later where they had some
sway
they had some power
um
this is they're like nobodies
so um at any rate yeah so he's he's
accepting it as a cultural given um
in fact you know what's interesting too
is there's a theologian who pointed out
that the very fact that peter is writing
this at all
is actually a really interesting sign
that something um is happening in the
churches in other words what what
scholars speculate is that slaves
perhaps for the first time in history
were hearing the gospel
and were you see in rome at that time
slaves were seen as less than human
um
really just not worth anything
and so the speculation is that that
christians are sorry slaves had joined
the christian churches um because they
could be accepted there right most
religions it was like no no no no no
you're not welcome
right but they could be accepted so they
were they're participating in the
churches they're hearing the gospel
they're hearing about their inherent
dignity and worth and how we're all you
know there's i mean think of like paul's
teachings we are there's neither um jew
nor gentile
um male nor female slave nor free
for we are all made one in christ jesus
so these kind of ideas are floating
around in the christian community um
so
that that these christian slaves are
kind of for the first time starting to
hear these teachings starting to get a
sense of like wait i have worth i have
dignity i'm a somebody
and um
so what does like what does that mean
for me
you know like there's certain
implications like it's sort of starting
to make waves and so um
it seems that like this is why i think
peter's not saying you know slavery is
completely and totally aligned with the
gospel of jesus christ that's that's not
what he's doing instead he's really
acting more like a pastor who has
christian slaves in his congregation
and they're trying to figure out what do
we do now
how do we relate now
like we're free in christ but
what does that mean in this context at
this time all right so that's the first
contextual kind of context insight um
second insight is that the relational
dynamic peter is speaking to is not
occurring within the church but actually
outside of it
in other words notice that the dynamic
is not um
christian
slave owners to christian slaves that's
not peter's context
that could eventually that was a thing
obviously but in terms of peter's
context that's not what's going on we
know this partly because the masters are
nowhere addressed in this text
so what the dynamic is it's actually
christian slaves
to um
pagan or unbelieving slave owners
that can you see how that might
complicate things because it's i mean
it's one thing it changes something if
you have like um christian like masters
and slaves in the same congregation then
we'd probably expect peter like to
change something and we actually see it
in the book of philemon where you have
the apostle paul writing to a christian
master
about a christian slave and he's like
really kind of starting to push like
treat him as a brother
you know he just starts kind of really
starting to push back we don't see that
in this text why
because it's it's a different context
it makes sense it's a christian slave
and you can't go to like you know the
roman slave master like well i'm free in
christ we are brothers you know
that's just
not going to get you anywhere um
there's also um
i think kind of the question of um
like well that would potentially even be
um dangerous
right for
them to to try to start pushing back or
something so which we'll actually we'll
get to in a in a minute so um kind of
over and over again we see this is the
difficult context peter's trying to work
with right it's whether it was the
government like last week christian
um people in in in the empire relating
to rome
christian slaves relating to
pagan slave owners
that's the the trickiness of of what
peter is i'm kind of dealing with so
um
i think this is why like having these
two insights this is why i think it was
somewhat um i think it was obscene for
white christian
um slave owners or even people who just
supported slavery in the united states
to use this text to defend their
position
right because they just wanted to do
kind of a surface reading of it just
well it says you know slaves obey your
master so look no further ask no more
questions delve no more into the minutia
of the text and what's actually going on
and what is peter addressing and like no
no we just want to kind of keep it easy
breezy high level let's move on
and actually when you get into it it's
like no
this is um this is not apples to apples
so here um
really we're coming right back to a
primary theme of this whole series
um which is a question about culture
it's a question about um how do we as
christians relate to culture and not
just the idea of culture like in the
abstract you know whatever that would
mean culture but i mean like how do
christians relate to practical
everyday things going on in the culture
like that's really that's what peter's
wrestling with as a pastor that's what
these christian slaves were wrestling
with like
how do we relate to this culture
we are
in
um
because basically they're you know they
can say like yes we're all one in christ
we're as a song we're just singing free
at last free last like yes that is true
and yet we walk out the doors of the
church like in the church at least for
peter's context apparently there was a
lot of equality
we'll get into this some next week we
know from quotes from romans that
christians were really looked down upon
because they just accept anyone you've
got slaves and women and i mean i
realize that sounds super sexist and
terrible but that's what the romans were
saying about these christians these are
awful people
so
that's what they're experiencing right
their experience that's their context in
the church it's different they walk out
the doors
that's not reality right so that's the
question how do how do we relate to
culture um there's a theologian named
miroslav wolfe and he wrote
a little essay it's like 19 pages or so
um titled soft difference you can find
it online if you're into academic things
it's a little bit academic but he's
basically writing about the book of
first peter and specifically about this
question
how do christians negotiate culture how
do we relate to things in the culture
um
and he has this this quote that i really
loved he said there is no single proper
way for christians to relate to a given
culture as a whole
instead there are numerous ways of
accepting rejecting subverting or
transforming
various aspects of
culture
i love this i love how nuanced this is
because i think the um where christians
have gone wrong in the past is that we
get super clunky and we get super locked
into like one of these
you know so maybe it's like accept like
if it's in the culture
it is the will of god that it be in the
culture
therefore to oppose it is to oppose the
very will of god
therefore accept everything
right this of course leads to tremendous
injustice like this is terrible um
on the other hand if you go the reject
route right of just like hey if it's in
the culture
it's bad
right like you can imagine for example
missionaries people um christians who go
into a different culture to spread the
word of jesus and share the gospel they
have to negotiate this
right they have to figure out what do we
accept
what do we reject because if they just
come to the culture and they're just
like this culture is a terrible culture
we reject it
all of you are just awful in every way
all of your social practices
everything's bad i reject this in the
name of the jesus who is love right you
can see that like that
it's problematic you know but on the
other hand if they just accept it all
well then you're like in conflict with
the gospel you're in conflict with can
you see the trickiness here let's say
hello what do you do this is why wolf
says there's no like one single way
there's no like easy answer like well i
just accept culture well i just reject
cultures well
um
it's not that it's just not that easy um
i think
well he okay so it's accept reject those
are our first two and then he has these
other two subvert and transform
um let's talk about transform what does
it mean to transform culture i think
this is where um and how does it
specifically differ from subvert when i
think um transform we'll talk about
severt in a minute um so when i say
transform i think of something that
christians do openly
right it's like we see something in the
culture and we're like
that is problematic
and we are going to change it
right um but it's very in the open like
i think back we talked a few weeks ago
about how christians as they related to
the roman empire they realized that the
poor
um were being completely neglected the
sick completely neglected and so they
said
we're going to do something about that
and it wasn't a secret like they were
just going out
taking people in helping right that's
them they're transforming the culture we
talked about how they um would take
babies that were left to die on the
edges of towns and christians were known
to go out and they would collect the
children and then raise them as their
own that's an example where they see
something in the culture and they're
like yep we need to transform that
um
now this brings up the question okay so
what does it mean to subvert
now we can get that definition let's get
the definition of subvert it means to
undermine the power and authority of a
given system or institution
you can see that the word subvert it's a
little more
sneaky
right if i tell my kiddo don't subvert
my authority
all right what do i mean do i mean
they're openly trying to oppose what i'm
getting across or what i'm trying to get
done no
i mean they're being sneaky about it
right there it's subtle
and that's what the word subvert means
so
when i think of what peter and the early
christians did
um
and specifically when it came to slavery
i don't they did not opt for reject for
just outright rejection
um why this goes back to the point i
made earlier about probably because it
would have been dangerous
right they have no power in the culture
did they just tell their these christian
slaves in the in the community like
we'll just go and just declare your
freedom or run away or do something like
this probably just gonna be dangerous so
they didn't opt for reject um
they they off also did not opt for
transform
right just kind of an open like hey this
is bad
and it's probably because they were
living in a military dictatorship you
know it's tough like if you're in north
korea right now to like let's protest
let's change things you know it's well
yeah you know so they didn't do that and
said what did what and and also i would
say the reason probably the passage
strikes us as somewhat kind of just
cringy and like uh is because it sounds
like peter's going for the accept option
right isn't that why it kind of hits us
as like
but i don't think that's actually what
peter's doing is that i think what he's
doing is subverting
what do i mean if you're taking notes
you can write this down peter laid the
groundwork for subverting slavery
by equating
the noble and unjust suffering of christ
with the suffering of slaves
this is where i think he starts he's
taken and we read it and we just kind of
miss it because we're just sort of
shocked by the you know the cultural gap
from 2000 years ago today we're just
like i don't know what's going on here
but it's terrible
run you know don't preach a sermon on it
for sure avoid avoid a void you know um
but actually i think he's
he's just starting to lay the groundwork
for for a shift in the culture
let's go ahead and we're going to read
again we'll start with the last verse of
the passage we read earlier and then
we'll keep going into verses 22 through
24 so starting verse 21 he says to this
you were called because christ suffered
for you leaving you an example that you
should follow in his steps
he jesus committed no sin no deceit was
found in his mouth when they hurled
their insults at him he did not
retaliate when he suffered he made no
threats instead he entrusted himself to
him who judges justly he himself bore
our sins and his body on the cross so
that we might die to sins and live for
righteousness by his wounds you have
been healed you see what peter's doing
is he's naming
to his
congregation like to real people he's
saying as a slave you will be unjustly
treated
you will be
oppressed you will be mocked you will be
insulted you will even be beaten like
that will happen and in that moment
you will be like christ
suffering on
the cross
now the implication there
is and who are the slave owners
they are like those who put jesus on
the cross like can you see how this is
not exactly a glowing endorsement
of the institution of slavery like we're
miles away from well every institution
has been established by god so
like no he's being sneaky here
he's he's starting he's undermining the
story in rome a story
about how might makes right
that's the culture in rome it's like if
you're in charge you're right and if
you're weak well then you lose and you
have no value you're a worthless person
and what's he doing he's starting to
equate he's connecting the suffering of
christ the the noble and unjust
suffering of christ on the cross with
that of
the slaves
um
i think this is why
um what you have with
writers like peter
and paul
what you have with the story of the
crucified jesus who died the death of a
slave in that culture a roman citizen
could not be crucified
only slaves thieves kind of low class or
foreigners
that's who could be crucified so he dies
as a slave so what you have in in that
story the story of christ and the
writings of peter and paul
um is i would call them kind of the
first rumblings of ideas that would
eventually transform the world that
would eventually lead to the abolition
of slavery um now just to be clear
peter's writings are not
are not abolition themselves right
clearly like he's not saying in this
evil institution coincidentally it's
interesting you have 300 years later a
guy named gregory of nissa
um christian bishop
and he's the first person in recorded
history in written history that we have
who did actually say for the first time
this slavery as an institution is evil
and is in contradiction to the gospel
he's the first person that we know of in
the world i mean maybe someone can find
something that's before from the sources
i looked into they said as far as we
know this is the first one
so you do have that 300 years after
peter's writing
right so
and clearly peter's not saying that
right you might think of it like a like
an earthquake sometimes before an
earthquake like a day or two before you
have the tremors
sort of the rumblings
and then like two or three days later
it's like boom you know or the volcano
gonna boom like and and i would think of
peter's writings peter is he's the
tremors
and then 300 years later with gregory
nissa and then later
um you have
the the actual um the gospel kind of
undermining these
narratives
and the story of the crucified one
completely changed the world and
eventually um
leading to the end of of slavery
so
okay so that's a lot of history and a
lot of um background and context all
sorts of things now some of you are like
whoa this is a lot um i want to ask the
question okay so
what does this mean for our lives
you know it'd be easy to kind of like
well great lesson
um
what do i do tomorrow different you know
and and i think this is a little bit of
a challenge because clearly in the
united states like well
slavery's illegal you know so
i don't know how this matters today um
but i think actually if we just zoom out
just a little bit i think it's it's
pretty clear so i want to give you um
two things two ways that i think two
kind of principles
that i think do apply to our lives um
the first is this we need communal
discernment in the holy spirit's
guidance about what in culture to accept
reject subvert or transform
that's this is a big deal right because
again this isn't just about oh that
happened way long ago well man too bad
that's terrible they had to deal with
all that
you know i'm glad that nowadays
all our problems are solved you know
and no
no right now i say communal discernment
because this isn't as simple as just i
don't know getting opinions you know
like i'm an individual and i've got an
opinion this is what i think you know
there's there's something um
deeply i think good and wise about
coming together as a community
to talk
um
to pray
to process things in the culture to and
and sometimes argue right it's not
always easy um i mean hopefully not like
screaming matches but you know what i
mean like
speaking honestly
speaking honestly and when we do that
what what are we wrestling with we're
wrestling with how does the gospel touch
down in our culture like today and now
what do we accept
what do we reject what do we subvert
what do we transform
these are tremendous questions
and um
we've got to be
thinking them through we've got to be
working through together all right
second um second principle we need
communal discernment and the holy
spirit's guidance about when to
transition from subvert
to reject
or transform
um
because i think it's a really fair
question to ask
okay brett yes
the logic of the gospel kind of worked
itself out in culture and eventually led
to the end of slavery um why did it take
900 years
yeah that's a fair question
and and i think what happened was
the the church started in subvert
and then
got comfortable with subvert
you know kind of being
subtle and maybe early on it was
necessary
but after like a few hundred years
was it still necessary did we have to be
so sneaky
what and what happened then we go from
subvert and then eventually we just
start sliding towards
accept
i mean it's just the way it is
right and that's honestly that's i think
the natural slide we kind of maybe start
off with some good intentions like well
let's subvert things subtly give it time
though
and then all of a sudden before you know
it you have accept and then
the way it played out in our culture of
course is not just accept like ah
begrudgingly
um but even
defend to the death
things that are completely in
contradiction to the gospel of jesus
christ
like
can you see this is
like we went incredibly wrong because
this is another fair question is like
how how did a so-called christian nation
how did a so-called christian nation
not only accept but defend to the death
an institution like this like
and and not just i mean even slavery
like even if you look at the cultural
differences like roman slavery you know
there was things where you could be born
into it but it wasn't even based on like
race
um
they did conquer peoples and things and
like make them slaves
um
but i mean if you think of like what the
west did you know like literally just
going and stealing people from a
continent and like there was like a
whole way like it was like a uniquely
pernicious and evil form of slavery
that's what i'm trying to get at right
it was just like
god with even no clear exit path like
that's in rome you actually could
in certain instances not always but kind
of work your way up and then be freed or
there could even be time limits on it
like if you owe a lot of money you'll be
a slave for like seven years
and then after that it's like okay debt
paid you're done like
again that wasn't necessarily super
widespread but it existed i mean how did
the u.s
here like what what happened
we start with subvert
and we just slide
towards accept
now
my point isn't to just get on a soapbox
and
rant you know
what i want to ask the question is let
me phrase it i'll put it in a form of a
statement from me
this puts the fear of the lord into me
because here's the question
what am i currently accepting
that i should not be accepting
what am i currently rejecting
that i shouldn't be rejecting
what am i currently subverting and being
kind of subtle about that actually is no
it's not time to be subtle
what should i be transforming that i'm
not transforming
and by the way here's what's really um
tricky as human beings um there's
something there's a saying that you the
one thing you can't give yourself is
outside perspective
all right so with that one
can't do that can you and this is what's
so crazy is we just tend to think that
we're right
everyone does we all do it's kind of
like no no i pretty much got it right
you know 90
it's like
maybe
probably not
which is where we come back to we need
communal discernment
in the holy spirit's guidance they say
oh god help us reveal to us
what what
what do i need to accept what do i need
what do we i'll put in the we what do we
need to accept what do we need to reject
subvert transform
and of course this applies it's all
sorts of things i mean everything from i
mean what would it be how how to care
for the poor and the marginalized
we talked a few weeks ago about um
abortion
um
uh ongoing issues with racial injustice
and inequality i mean there's all sorts
of things
that are a massive prayerful communal
conversation
that we need to be happening so i i
think let me kind of close by saying
this may the table may it always be a
place where we can have those
conversations
may your meetups
your small groups be a place where you
can have those kinds of conversations
may your dinner table
be a place
where you can have those kinds of
conversations
because then maybe
christ could break through
in this world like the kingdom of god
could come in more
pure and beautiful
clear
ways you bow your heads
close your eyes let me go ahead and
close this with a prayer lord jesus
we desperately need your wisdom
your self-awareness
conviction
courage
we desperately need your visionary
as opposed to a reactionary way of being
in the world
in order to know what to accept
reject
subvert and transform
may you search our hearts god
may you show us if there be any hurtful
way in us
anyway we aren't bringing our lives into
alignment with your liberating
loving life-giving way
help us to be faithful
in the name of the father the son and
the holy spirit
amen
you guys feel free to stay seated if you
would like
but the words will be up and we invite
you to sing along um
i love the song and the message that it
contains
as god has continued to pull us towards
transformation
and
having
a kingdom of god that is
not only open to all people
but celebrating and calling us to
freedom and transforming us there
uh when i was practicing the song
uh
i found it really hard
to sing the chorus because
the questions brett was just asking
is
you know you look around in the world
and
i know
christian people and
that don't necessarily
give out the loving vibe
uh and i'm in that boat too i'm sure i
don't give out the loving vibe all the
time but
i'm singing the kingdom is yours and i'm
asking myself the question do i do i
want them to have this kingdom
am i
you know portraying
the
love of this kingdom that this song is
talking about
so
it kind of falls in suit with what brett
was saying and now it's making sense as
to why i was having these feelings
and why it was hard for me to sing
because i was asking myself am i
providing am i bringing the kingdom here
for other people
so asking those questions
yeah it hit me so
uh anyways i'm gonna try and sing it i
when i first sang at home i was like i
try i never i don't like to cry so you
know i like saying that i'll choke up
cough it off and my voice is crying
anyways
sing along with us
and blessed are the ones who do not bury
all the broke pieces of their
[Music]
stars
brave enough to show the lord their
scars
[Music]
the kingdom
is yours
the kingdom is yours
[Music]
hold on a little more
this is not the end
hope is in the lord keep your eyes on
him
[Music]
even in the face of great abuse
serving with unguarded gratitude
are the ones who fight for justice
longing for the coming day of feasts
blessed is the soul that thirsts for
righteousness
welcoming the last
[Music]
hold on a little more this
the is is in the lord keep your eyes on
him
the kingdom is
[Music]
the kingdom is yours
hold on a little more this is not the
end
hope is in the lord keep your eyes on
him
[Music]
wow
blessed are the ones who suffer
violence
and still have strength to love their
enemies
[Music]
the kingdom is yours
hold on a little more this is not the
end
hope is in the lord keep your eyes on
here
the kingdom is yours
[Music]
hold on a little more
this
[Music]
is in the lord keep your eyes on him
hold on a little more this is not the
end
hope is in the lord keep your eyes on
him
[Music]
thank you lord
clearly we need wisdom
moment by moment day by day because
every day
every moment of every day we find
ourselves confronted by the world around
us in some way
i love these words from james if any man
meaning human lack wisdom
let him ask of god who gives to all
men
liberally
and without reproach in that word
reproach means without looking for
reason to deny your request
so let's ask for wisdom together right
now just momentarily and then if anybody
would like a prayer of agreement
at the end of the service concerning
this wisdom
or the wisdom of healing the wisdom of
whatever
i'll be up here be happy to pray with
you happy to offer that prayer of
agreement
happy to offer you some encouragement
father
we ask for that wisdom
to flow as it flows richly and
abundantly to be perceptive of it as we
are confronted daily
with the issues of this world
thank you father we receive that wisdom
with gratitude in the name of your son
jesus
[Music]
oh wait there we go once again we want
to invite the visitors any visitors we
have to fill out the card
just outside this door to my left down
here and place it in the box please and
again
the welcome to the table
uh
[Music]
gathering on the 20th right after the
service
if you're interested in that we went
again to when you fill out that card in
the hallway write wtt
uh welcome to the table in the comments
section please
so that
we can
contact you and make sure that you are
in attendance
praise god
if you'd stand i want to just speak over
you this benediction
and i know it's become our custom and
it's a good custom to posture ourselves
with our hands in such a way as to
welcome the benediction but i want you
to also
more importantly posture your mind in
your heart
because many times the words of these
benedictions i believe don't quite
leave us in an attitude of consideration
and thinking thought
these things need to be taken into your
thought life
these things need to be meditated upon
so if you posture your heart as well
in your mind as well as i speak this
over you
i believe you'll receive a
greater opportunity
you are included
included in the eternal life of the
father son and holy spirit
included from before time began
and now in time
assured of this eternal inclusion
through the revelation of jesus christ
the savior of all men
you are included not by your knowledge
or belief
not by your profession of faith or a
confession of a creed
not by any religious practice
or the abstinence
or
of any particular creed of holiness
you are included solely by the
predetermined will and declaration of
the father
and the gospel revelation in christ
in whom this word was made flesh and
dwells among us
may you be blessed in receiving the
revelation
of this benediction amen
praise the lord you're dismissed
foreign
i